I don't know if I ever told you ball
like how much like I Vibe with horses I
[__] love those things man I love
them to the point I would never if I
owned one I would never ride it dude we
should go halves he's on a horse dude
and [__] give it the best stable and
pay and we just [__] split the
character you know what you just said
Paul we should go broke
Paul because you know God damn well
there's no way us two idiots could own a
horse unless we were racing it
I
if I wouldn't go broke Paul I I would
like I would rescue a hundred of those
things and just let him never ride them
let them chill dude me and you would get
a horse and we would have to name it if
we raced it we would have to name it
anything better and there's anything
better on the outside